hey guys so i'm so excited because today
it's the day do you guys remember when i
did the unboxing of the gold macbook and
i told you guys that i was contemplating
giving this one away because i had
actually ordered the silver one for
myself and i was gonna return the gold
one but then i thought
since my book is coming out i wanted to
have sort of a little celebration for
you guys a celebration for the book and
do a fun giveaway so the macbook is
officially going to be somebody's so i'm
gonna put a link in the description
where you guys can find out all the
information how you can win it there's
only i think a few days left for you
guys to enter and if you pre-order my
book and put in the pre-order code you
get extra chances to win but no purchase
is necessary for the entering of the
macbook i'm also giving away a bunch of
other fun things i think i told you guys
this in one of my previous videos i
wanted to do a little comparison of
previous generation macbooks this is oh
my god it's so heavy
it's weird that this is heavy this is
the retina the 15-inch retina it's one
of the first ones that came out and this
is the
silver i need i need something to open
this with when i'll just use my teeth we
like to keep it classy here how's it
going jen good so here's what i'm going
to do since i did already open up the
gold one i'm going to give you all of
the insides of
okay come on i'm gonna give you the
fresh new charger and stuff from this
one and just put it into
the gold box for you
with love from justine and i think i
will i'll throw a little postcard in
there too
click open pick the tour date's
officially been announced for my book as
well this seems like a big book promo
but it's basically all i have been
living for the past couple of
uh past year as a matter of fact
actually i'll be going to
new york this weekend new jersey do i go
to pittsburgh first and then chicago yes
and then dallas and then seattle yes i
think that sounds about right oh my god
oh the smell of like
a new computer
really gets me going and as you can see
holy moly it is freaking thin
it's freaking thin that's like basically
all i have to say i also finally just
got in the mail jenna what are you doing
would you do me a big favor what's up
there's something on my desk i hate it
it's by the pc it's the it's a three
port usbc converter so i finally got
that which just came in so look at this
this box is all fresh for you i'm just
going to transfer all of those things
into the gold one i'm even going to save
this i'll put the macbook back in there
this is yours
new macbook charger new directions
because really we really need those
and here's jenna's computer
this is wow this is i don't even
remember which version this is well this
sucker is a hefty
little pig
it wasn't usually everything is where
it's okay so this is the usbc digital av
multi-port adapter to be completely
honest with you i'm not even sure what
this has okay this has usb-c which
hopefully will allow me to connect this
and then be able to
charge
because if not that's gonna suck why are
you not focusing have you not been out
have you been off this whole time
because if that's if that's the case i'm
gonna be real upset what are you are you
ruining my day
oh
hey back in focus now it's really
unfortunate but
i don't know what to say now that we're
in focus hopefully the rest of this
video wasn't too terrible or too painful
here's the usbc converter direct from
apple
usbc i'm like what i can't believe it
here's the
apple comparison the bottom one is the
15-inch retina and this one above it is
jenna's computer which i don't 100
remember
which model this is it was probably a
few years
before this
retina came out so it's probably almost
maybe six years old i'm doing my macbook
math correctly and the top one is the
new macbooks that just were recently
released and in comparison to the gold
we'll show you guys the the luscious
color since now i'm in focus
whoa
these look like the same exact color in
this lighting like if i were to hold
this up right now and look into the
screen like i could i can't even tell
which ones which even was it looks
exactly like the same color like we look
so much like the same person
can't tell alright guys well thank you
so much for watching i look forward to
doing the giveaway to officially put
this new macbook into somebody else's
loving home so you better love it and
you better send me selfies because i'm
going to miss it but i know it's gonna
be going to a good home so i hope to see
you guys on book tour if you guys
haven't pre-ordered make sure you get it
do what you do actually we're gonna be
giving away some audio
ones as well but there's there's too
much going on for me to deal with that
so i'll see you guys later i love you um
see you soon bye